Hey, welcome back to 40 Days of Holiness. Let's grab a workbook.
Today, we're going to take some notes and we're going to talk.
This is going to be one of the toughest things to explain in all this, so put on
your thinking cap, buckle up, and let's talk about day 13.
God provided holiness in Jesus on the cross.
I want to start with a song called "In the Blood" by John Mayer.
I want you to listen as he wrestles with his heart and how it keeps him tied to the
sin in his life, and we're going to transition.
Here's what he wrote: How much of my mother has my mother left in
me? How much of my love will be insane to some degree?
And what about this feeling that I'm never good enough?
Will it wash out in the water
or is it always in the blood?
How much of my father am I destined to become?
Will I dim the lights inside me just to satisfy someone?
Will I let this woman kill me or do away with jealous love?
Will it wash out in the water or is it always in the blood?
I can feel the love I want, I can feel the love I need,
but they're never going to come the way I am.
Could I change it if I wanted? Could I rise above the flood?
Will it wash out in the water or is it always in the
blood?
Do you feel what he's struggling with there?
Is it just in me? Is this just who I am? It's in my blood.
I can't ever be rid of it. All of this.
John, if you're listening, I know what you need. You need better blood.
You need some blood flowing in your veins that was shed 2,000 years ago.
The blood of Jesus can change that.
Hebrews 13:12 says, "And so Jesus also
suffered outside the city gate to make the people holy through
his own blood." So let's recap real quick.
God's holy. He requires holiness.
He wills it for his people. He taught us about how to get
there, but our own nature of unholiness means we can't
create it or reach it in our own lives.
But today, I've got good news. God decided to
provide holiness as a gift. He
provides holiness through justification, through
imputing to me the righteousness of Jesus Christ, his
obedience for my sin, and this is when he declares us
not guilty. 2 Corinthians 5:21 says, "God
made him who had no sin to be made sin for us
so that we might become the righteousness of God in him."
But does God only provide judicial holiness, like I declare you not
guilty? No. He also provides us with dynamic, actual
holiness as well. Ephesians 5:25 says, "Just as
Christ loved the church and gave himself up for her to make her
holy, cleansing her." Now, that's not actually the best translation
here. The NIV marginal translation in the sidebar is actually more
accurate here. Here's what it ought to say.
It should say, "Having cleansed her."
Having cleansed his church. So here's the way the Greek
really should be translated. Let's go back to Ephesians 5:25 and read it that way.
"Just as Christ loved the church and gave himself up for her
to make her holy, having cleansed her." So I want you to
point out that this cleansing, washing is before the rest
of the holiness that God provides.
So he provides cleansing and washing, and he's got more, right?
We're washed and cleansed, and then holiness continues.
So remember how God delivered his people in order to
go out and make his covenant with them and make them holy?
He took them out of Egypt, away from sin, broke the old gods
through the 10 plagues, and he took them figuratively through
the baptism waters of the Red Sea, and then he brings
them to the holy mountain to make his covenant of holiness with them,
to make them holy as he is holy,
right? The blood of Christ contains all the atonement that's
necessary to forgive us, but also for every
phase of our Christian life. It doesn't wash out in the water,
no, but it does wash out in the blood.
Now, imagine that this bottle
is rolled in mud. It's both dirty and it doesn't sit
straight. Right? It's dirty and it doesn't sit straight.
Romans 8 tells us that in God's sight, we are justified and
glorified in God's sight. So the one who inhabits eternity, who
sees the end and the beginning. In the same way, God
comes and takes us out of the mud,
washes us clean, and he sees the full journey that he
has us on. He sees that he's going to grant us a full
measure of his holiness. He sees us as we are,
but he calls us what we will be.
The scope of salvation, right? Romans 8 says we're justified
and glorified in God's eyes. So he sees it all.
Oh, don't miss this. He is committed to the whole
journey of bringing about everything that he's
provided. He provides holiness on the cross, and
then he sets about creating in reality what he gifted to
us. He knows that our nature is a lack, an
empty. There's an emptiness we were born with.
He knows he's going to restore it. So he says,
"You're sanctified. You're holy." And then he goes about
creating in reality
what he has gifted to us in a moment.
Now, don't miss this.
He says you're sanctified, you're holy, and then he goes
about making it so in our actual lives.
He goes about actually straightening out, actually
restoring, actually rebuilding everything that sin has
broken. Holiness is gifted to us at
the new birth. God sees the whole thing, and in a moment, he declares
us holy before we have done anything
holy. He says, "You're saints."
Why?
Because it won't wash out in the water,
but it will wash out in the blood of Jesus. Right?
That's where it's at. God is granting to us
in a moment of time the holiness that he is now going to
produce in us in
time. So in a moment, he says, "I grant to you, I see
you as holy, and now I'm going to make you holy
in every single way." Now, I'll talk about
tomorrow and over the rest of the time how God goes about doing
that. But the good news is that in a moment of time, God
gifts to us that which we don't have.
He says, "You're mine. You're holy. I choose you.
I select you, and now I'm going to make you, on an ongoing
basis, holy."
I don't know if I'm doing an adequate job explaining that one. Stick with me, okay?
We're going to continue learning this and explaining how
God produces what he has already created and declared
us to be. All right? God bless you. See you tomorrow.